Hello!  There's lots of reasons to be concerned about rape.
Bill Cosby.  Mike Tyson.  Ben Worthless-berger.
Wherever you Turners, there's rape.
And what's one of the most common questions asked besides why don't we castrate rapists
since they've proven themselves untrustworthy members of society?
That's right!  What were you wearing?
Now, finally comes the answer that we've all been waiting for!
Introducing Rape Prevention Leggings!
He can't rape you if he can't find your vagina.
I wanna rape but there's nothing here!
Rape prevention leggings promises to prevent rape or your trauma back guaranteed!
Don't wait!  Become unrapeable today!
With Rape Prevention Leggings.
I can't rape!
Rape Prevention Leggings promises to prevent rape.
Or your trauma back guaranteed!
Don't wait!  Make yourself unrapeable today!
With Rape Prevention Leggings!